what do you have to do to get kicked out
of the commons chamber often it's using
our parliamentary language like calling
a colleague a liar but today it was
Rowdy heckling from this man Tory MP
Paul Bristow controlled immigration
looks like all they've got to do is wake
up tomorrow morning listen to the
headlines and see what this government
ordered Miss Bristol I think you're
going to be leaving
I'm asking you to leave no because
otherwise I'll name it
[Applause]
on this side
I was in the chamber at that moment and
you could feel the change in atmosphere
now tomorrow we're expecting to see the
publication of record immigration
numbers so today kirst armor tried to
announce new policy in that very area
changing the minimum salary levels when
granting visas to foreign workers but it
all got rather lost amongst his jokes at
the expense of the Home Secretary who
won't now face an Ethics inquiry after
allegedly asking civil servants to
arrange a private speed awareness course
so why does he think his Home Secretary
seems to have such a problem coping with
points-based systems
but fear not because speeding into the
void left by the Prime Minister comes
the Home Secretary the Home Secretary
may need a speed awareness course he
needs a reality check
now labor advisors argue they are
determined not to concede ground on the
issue of immigration but the PM
responded that his government was doing
far more than laborwood including a new
policy this week
the biggest ever single measure to
tackle legal migration removing the
right for international students to
bring the pendants toughening the rules
on post-study work whilst we're getting
on with clamping down on legal migration
listening to the British public he's
perfectly comfortable wanting to say
that he wants free movement back
elsewhere the Prime Minister was asked
about corruption allegations concerning
a multi-million pound Redevelopment in
Northeast England
the cheese Works affair
honorable friend uh leveling up
secretary has already announced uh
owning an investigation into this matter
about claims some schools are supporting
pupils to socially transition changing
names or wearing clothes to match their
gender without informing parents will
the Prime Minister instruct the
Department of Education to order schools
to stop indoctrinating our children and
to concentrate on their duty of care to
protect them it is absolutely right that
schools are sensitive in how they teach
those matters and which they should be
done in an age-appropriate fashion the
department for education is currently
reviewing the sanctuary guidance and
curriculum
and he was also asked whether taxpayers
should be footing Boris Johnson's legal
bills for parliament's party gate
inquiry why can't he stand up for the
British people it's actually a long
established process across multiple
administrations that former ministers
are supported with legal representation
after they have left office to deal with
matters that relate to their time in
office
immigration was the main focus today and
it will likely be the same tomorrow
we're expecting those record immigration
stats to be published at 9 30 am